خيرسون ميكو لايف اوديسي وعلى الجانب
الاخر زبوجيا ودنيت ولوجاز
تستمر فيها مواجهات بين الجيش الروسي
والاوكراني ومع ذلك ترافقها الرسائل
ومؤشرات امكانيه مسار للتهدئه والتفاوض
مقد يعزز ذلك ايضا ترجيح مديره
الاستخبارات الامريكيه انخفاض وتيره
القتال في اوكرانيا خلال الاشهر المقبله
بسبب ما سيطرده الشتاء المقبل من بيئه
مختلفه
والسلام تردد على اكثر من اللسان في
تغريده على تويتر تهامه مستشار الرئيس
الاوكرانيا الرئيس الروسي بانه غير قادر
على التفاوض المتحدث باسم الكربلائي رمى
الكره في ملعب الطرف الاخر فبرر حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا بتجاهل الهواء الروسيه بشان
اتفاقيات ميسي اذا هناك ما يمكن اصلاحها
اما وزير الخارجيه البريطاني فقال ان اي
محادثه سلام في اوكرانيا يجب ان لا تستخدم
غطاء لتسلح روسيا
وان بلاده لم تلاحظ اي اشارات بان بوتين
مستعد للدخول في محادثه سلام بحسن نيه
بينما اعرب الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
في اتصال هاتفي مع نظيره الروسي عن امله
بانهاء الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا في اقرب
وقت ممكن امال معلنه تتزامن مع دعوه
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون الى منح
موسكو ضمانات امنيه ايجابي توازن معها في
حال اعاده الى التفاوض وهي الدعوه التي
جاءت بعد زيارته الى واشنطن مكرونه
الاساسيه هي الخوف من ان ياتي حلف النيه
الى ابوابها ونشر اسلحه يمكن ان تهددها
ولا تغيب عن هذه الامال تصريحات المستشار
الالماني
بان من المهم ابقاء قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه
مع الرئيس الروسي لتحينا لحظه انهاء الحرب
وجاء اعلان الرئيس الامريكي استعداده
لمناقشه روسيا بشان امكانيه انهاء الى عمل
القتاليه على ان تتخذ قرارات معينه
صاحبي قواتها من اوكرانيا ليعزز من زخم
امكانيه اختراق في جدار الحرب المستمره كل
هذه التطورات تاتي بينما تبدلت روسيا
واوكرانيا 120 اسيرا في اطار صفقه جديده
بين الجانبين وفي مكالمه مع ماكرون قال
رئيس الاوكراني ان هناك معه معاهده السلام
من 10 نقاط وفق الصيغه الاوكرانيه وان
المواقف بين كيف وباريس متقاربه تتضمن
المعاهده بنودا بينها الامن النووي
والسعاده وحده الاراضي الاخرانيه وامن
الطاقه وعوده جميع اسرى الحرب المحتجزين
في روسياف اما من وجهه نظر روسيا فان
التفاوض بدا يبدا من اعتراف بجمهوريه
روسيا على شبه جزيره القرم وتخلي اوكرانيا
مستقبلا عن الاسلحه النوويه وعدم طرقها
ابواب حلف النيته في المنظور القديم